we have a family missing in these
earthquakes that haven't been found due
to the cold weather we're not hopeful
um we're quite worried when people
people can come together just be you
know just give as much as you can we
need Manpower on the ground now as well
as money coming in money to buy supplies
but we're desperate for Manpower we need
the governments over there to stand up
to start sending the Army in to start
standing up and helping their people
like I said there's areas there that
there's no one there to help them we're
watching this stuff but videos are being
sent over from us from uh people that
are in places and grounds that have been
flattened and they're trying to pull
their families out their families are
alive but they just can't get them out
because they don't have the Machinery
they don't have the Manpower they don't
have any help they have no food they
have no water they have nowhere to live
so we just need Manpower